hey this is really funny um donald trump
essentially almost accidentally conceded
on friday this this is just amazing you
know trump continues to claim victory he
continues to
claim fraud even this morning he tweeted
that he won
but he has been essentially in hiding
other than um laying a wreath on
veterans day
until friday the white house announces a
big
press conference to talk about not
conceding no
to talk about coronavirus vaccines and
the expectations were
trump would not take questions he didn't
take questions but yet he still made
this event hilarious and pathetic
remember
trump keeps tweeting every single day i
won biden lost
it was fraud or fraud as he says
it was fake and all of this stuff but
during his press conference on friday
trump almost accidentally admits he did
lose
he brings up lockdowns and he says he
doesn't want lockdowns
he wouldn't do lockdowns and then as he
realizes he's sort of about to refer to
the biden administration
he finds a way out of it just by the
skin of his teeth take a look
and hundreds of thousands of jobs every
single day
ideally we won't go to a lockdown i will
not go this administration will not be
going to a lockdown hopefully the
the whatever happens in the future who
knows which administration will be i
guess time will tell but
i can tell you this administration will
not go to a lockdown
there won't be necessity lockdowns cost
lives and they caused a lot of problems
he's about to say hopefully the biden
administration
which of course is incoming but then he
realizes wait a second i'm scamming my
followers that i won
i can't say that so he says whatever
happens in the future and this entire
event
felt like an event put together for
trump's ego and i'm reminded
as some of you know donald trump's late
father fred trump
uh had dementia quite quite serious
dementia towards the end of his life
and at a certain point they sort of
concocted like a fake work environment
for fred trump where he would still go
into work and he'd have papers on his
desk
and he would have a phone and he would
think he was working but when he would
pick up the phone it would only
the only person he could get was his
secretary out in the main room
and um this almost feels like a version
of that for trump where
pfizer had already said listen we
weren't part of operation warp speed
and uh trump's on his way out trump lost
but they sort of like set up a show
press conference for trump to feel like
he's doing stuff here is a military
general for example sucking up to trump
mr president thank you for allowing me
to continue service
of our great nation as a co-leader with
dr monsef solawi on this mission
trump does say we won't be delivering
the vaccine to new york
and this is another instance of trump
wanting to i guess attack governor
andrew cuomo take a listen
as soon as april the vaccine will be
available to the entire general
population
with the exception of places like new
york state where
for political reasons the governor
decided to say and you know
i don't think it's good politically i
think it's very bad from a health
standpoint but
uh he wants to take his time with the
vaccine he doesn't
trust where the vaccine's coming from
these are coming from the greatest
companies anywhere in the world greatest
labs in the world now that's a total lie
what new york governor andrew cuomo said
is he has a problem with
trump's demands for um
a lot of information about everybody
who's vaccinated which andrew cuomo
fears could be
used by ice and immigration authorities
to come and start
finding undocumented immigrants in new
york and andrew cuomo doesn't want
vaccination to be used for those
purposes it is not about
uh what uh donald trump makes it out to
be it's not vaccine skepticism or
anything of the like trump's just
just lying and here is the other clip i
really want you to take a look at take a
listen to this
pfizer said it wasn't part of warp speed
but that turned out to be a
unfortunate misrepresentation they are
part that's why we gave them the 1.95
million
billion dollars and uh it was an
unfortunate mistake that they made when
they said that
yeah so this is um
this is a so so let me see if i can
explain how this goes
trump did operation warp speed where he
did fund
research for some vaccines and
the pfizer vaccine is not one of them
okay
what trump is arguing here is that
because pfizer agreed to sell a bunch of
vaccines to the government
if indeed they get an approved vaccine
trump says
they did participate in operation warp
speed
the problem is trump's trying to argue
the vaccine from
pfizer is almost done thanks to money
from the trump administration that's not
true
in other words if you come to me and you
say hey david
um if you develop a really great
electric car
i will buy a bunch of them but i'm not
giving you any money right now
and there's nothing i'm giving you
that's going to help you develop the car
but if you develop the car
i want a deal that you will sell me 100
of these vehicles
that's essentially what happened here
and donald trump is trying to distort it
as always to try to take credit
and then trump in the end did wrap up
without taking any questions
and you're going to hear as trump kind
of slinks away
you're going to hear questions being
yelled like why do you think you won the
election and many others
everybody thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
so it's really unclear how much more
we're going to be seeing donald trump
during this presidency it could go a
number of ways
we could see he see him all the way up
to the inauguration continuing to claim
that he won
we could see trump leave the white house
for thanksgiving next week and
never come back we could see trump leave
the white house
for christmas in december and go to
florida and never go back to d.c
it really could go any number of ways
i'm wondering where you see it going
let me know i'm on twitter deepakman
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a life saver and here's how it
works takes just a couple of minutes to
set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give
each company a randomized virtual credit
card number that you create out of thin
air it'll even autofill the card number
with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy
the virtual card number right after
using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman